are you a pilot yeah you still a p do
you still fly I do what do you fly uh
the Cirrus uh uh Vision jet does that
have that's the one that has the
parachute yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
make great they have the SR22 and the
the vision jet and the vision jet is
phenomenal you have a vision jet I don't
I don't I don't have that kind of money
but I have uh friends at Cirrus that let
me fly with them and the fact that we
mentioned it on the podcast do we get a
cus
I mean lot sponsorship oh a lot of
podcasts aren't brought to you by
airplanes oh that's a good point isn't
it we could be the podcast of Cirrus we
should do a podcast up in the air and
then they'll give you airplanes but
that's the safest airplane I have a
friend that has one of those and that
that airplane if it should if things go
wrong uh the uh parachute comes out of
the back and it just floats down right
yep and there's there's actually two
really cool things about it first uh
there is a red button above that's cool
that a lot of people don't have a red
button blue they got yellow well but
they got red buttons like on the
dashboard but the fact that you have a
red button above here's the thing if the
pilot dies right which oh this is GNA be
funny this is GNA be funny you could
push the wait wait wait wait this is
going to be funny so we'll go to a
commercial this is a great hanging if
the pilot dies wait till you hear this
go
ahead you push the button and it lands
at
itself the plane lands itself it makes
all the calls makes all the radio calls
it does everything it comes into final
puts the gear down and lands hold on if
the pilot dies who's pressing the red
button any passenger anybody that's the
thing but we don't know that's why it's
a big red button that's what just the
pilot but here's here's no no no the
pilot briefs everybody before you get in
uhhuh oh instead of this is the exit or
this is the thing he goes look at this
red button I don't give a about
anything else if I go down push the red
button and sit sit back and relax enoy
fls like I wouldn't I wouldn't know
should every plane have that yeah why
doesn't you would think but no that's
why Sirus is very special and then then
I they should put that on American
Airlines no they should like if they
have Co they have co-pilots they have
co-pilots there in this is just one
pilot but I would think if I was flying
someplace thank God I hope he tells me
or she tells me because I would never
like that would be the last thing like
if I saw the pilot was dead I wouldn't
go up and start pressing buttons well
that's the thing like the cockpit is
here right but the big red safety button
is up here so it's very distinct very
distinct it's the only big red button
can I why wouldn't they just press the
red button anyways and sit back like a
Tesla like a self-driving thing yeah um
because uh uh I don't
know uh it's an emergency thing it
really it truly is I think it sends out
Emergency Signal it clears airspace it
it does things that that you don't want
to do on a regular flight okay so why
wouldn't you want to clear all all the
airspace and have a nice safe automatic
Landing with a wide birth no planes
around no nothing because it would upset
a lot of people trying to get to their
destination have you ever like just
accidentally as you're getting up out of
your seat press the red button no no no
no why where do you fly when you fly um
regionally so Phoenix Vegas see can San
Diego
hey
[Music]
he